The joe rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
That was a struggle to put that tweet out and I think I fucked it up as I was
releasing it and I was like,
bitch,
you didn't even spell check that.
Are you laying ladies and gentlemen?
Artie Lange?
Yeah,
I fucked it up.
Whatever.
I didn't do the right thing.
The colon was fucked up.
Whatever people figured out.
Oh,
any Langley's gentleman.
Artie Lange can play some fucking poor.
Oh yeah man.
You got a pool table out there.
I don't get this body running 10 miles a day,
but then now we played a couple of games.
Uber.
Do you a,
you kick some ass too.
It was fine.
It's fine.
Did you play in a pool hall as a kid or something?
Yeah,
well I tore my ACL 21 and a,
I couldn't work out until I got it fixed.
My friend Jon Tobin,
who was a standup comic from New York,
uh,
he,
he and I used to meet at this pool hall and just shit away our days,
you know,
comics and I just started playing an obsessive.
I got,
I got hooked on playing in tournaments and I went through a nutty time where I
couldn't stop playing pool.
I had all these delusions of grand jury.
I was never to have to work again because yeah,
I like,
like Jackie Gleason and the hustler,
the chubby fingers going h on the corner and so class go to when Paul Newman
goes,
look at that little Chubby guy walking around like a Chubby Ballerina.
What did the way he moves?
I go eight answer.
That's playing the violin and stick stuck between this chubby little finger.
Yeah,
that is amazing movie.
That's one of my all time favorite movies.
Absolutely.
I,
Jackie Gleason is a hell of an actor man.
And we were saying Jackie Gleason,
he might've been like the best celebrity pool player ever.
Like Jackie Gleason could run a hundred balls.
It's hard to find somebody.
Uh,
he almost beat Moscone once,
I think in straight pool didn't,
but almost it didn't.
But almost all of them about that.
That sounds like some bullshit for the Italian say over the fire.
Well,
it was this one time,
Jackie Gleason,
you got him on the fucking ropes.
Ropes.
Fucking Moscone didn't,
he was shitting himself and believe that this guy is going to be better than me
at everything.
I also have an uncle who told him he struck out Dominick Dimaio.
Oh,
Dominic Dimaggio.
Joe Dimaggio.
Retarded brother
retarded it was it a real Dominic Dominic and Joe.
I didn't know.
I was just making that up.
They all died,
broke really pretty much where it's pretty.
After the 1989 San Francisco earthquake,
that's where Joe Dimaggio live.
Cops found him walking around the city in the days with a suitcase full of a
$600,000 in cash.
So it was all from baseball card signings and shit.
And
how weird was he?
Was he just getting crazy as it got?
Who was,
who was Donald Lotion?
It was silos.
Marilyn Monroe plus he was that strong.
I bet it was.
It sounds like her and Rita Hayworth and magical fucking twats
like apparently to his girl.
Like he used to leave flowers,
her grave and Sinatra and Ava Gardner some checks on a slang.
It was Richard Richard Price.
I don't know why business is always complaining.
I got half the money in all the pussy.
What the fuck it cause it'd be a much shorter statement made about life.
Yeah.
And there's some women that just have the,
their currency.
Like there's social currency.
Is it worth just so much more than you can ever afford?
I am so happy just to be with them.
And Marilyn Monroe was just so powerful.
She was trying to hold onto a tornado or something like good luck keeping her.
Well that's exactly why they were trying to yeah cause they drive you crazy.
Yeah.
Who's the other guy was a Ginsberg.
Who did she live with as well?
So Arthur Miller.
Arthur Miller and the rd show.
Yeah.
Three I guess.
Uh,
yeah,
I'm a,
I'm a film historian.
Are you really?
I'm going to store in a lot of ways that like especially in sports,
I think,
well,
I don't know how I notice.
I have no idea how I remember this,
but you gave me the year between 1949 and the year 2000 so what?
51 years.
I'll give you the two teams who were in the world series and who won.
Holy Shit.
I don't know why.
I know if you want to do a couple of,
I'll do it and then we'll get out of it.
I wouldn't even know.
Does anyone know who won a world series?
These two guys,
they don't pick and pay attention to sports.
What am I am a view.
You're on males series title.
I'd literally have no idea who won this year.
Oh,
who's the world series champion this year?
I don't know who won last year.
I don't know.
I really don't know.
I know it sounds,
it sounds ridiculous.
Oh,
it doesn't.
I guess if you don't like baseball DWG like football,
right?
I don't even watch football.
Would he just likes that MMA shit.
I was kickboxing.
I watch MMA.
I watched those things.
Same Shit.
I watch boxing and that's all I pay attention to boxing.
I love Mayweather and a,
yeah.
What he's thing.
I think Mayweather is a very clever man.
Very clever man.
And setting the fight now is a good time.
It's a very good time.
I think so financially though time,
financially,
but it's also a good time for him as far as like success wise come manic Pacbio
was extremely dangerous just a few years ago,
like maybe even more so than he is now.
Some straps though,
there's a thought and it may not be correct because his last fight against
Brenda Reos,
he looked really fucking good and then Chris Algieri,
he looked really fucking good.
I mean he looks good dude.
He's a,
he's a beast.
Okay.
Manny Pacquiao was a beast.
I know,
I understand that.
I've seen the mark has knocked out when men will.
Mark has knocked him out,
knocked him out.
Dead cold one right hand,
Bam.
And the thought is when a guy gets turned off like that,
like maybe there's a little something that he lost.
Maybe there's a little step it Mike.
It's not always correct.
Sometimes guys bounce back from a knockout and they're fine.
It totally varies on the individual,
but
he always says they have to.
Frazier hit him with that first left and the first fight,
he was more apprehensive than ever,
wasn't his life.
You said it cost him the fight against Spinks and form him because all he saw
was that fucking,
I'm gonna fucking
but man.
And it affected the rest of his life.
It was a launching left towards guys throw himself feet were off the ground.
Man.
Did you ever watch the fight but change George Foreman and Joe Frazier?
Yes.
I like Frazier too,
but it's classic Howard Koh.
Sally Fallon was just something different back then,
man.
He was just something different.
He was hitting guys like 20% 30% harder than anybody ever seen.
Fight night back in the 70s was fun,
man.
It was,
I remember being a kid really getting like,
wow,
you know there's going to be fun.
Yeah.
I remember watching those ABC wide world of sports.
Alexis Arguayo would fight Arguayo prior.
Remember the two are glial prior fights.
Incredible.
The one they thought a,
uh,
priors fucking manager put us put schnapps and as to got them going,
well they thought it was coke.
Oh,
okay.
I thought it was,
but then he said it was liquor.
Maybe that doesn't make any sense.
More likely it was COPD.
If someone gave me a bunch of peppermint Schnapps,
I would not want to fight.
Now.
Well,
not only that,
I don't think you could just tell me if I'm wrong.
I don't think you could just drink coke.
Like if somebody puts cocaine in a glass and mixes it with waters,
the liquid cook that you shoot in your nose,
can you just rank it could pick up Stevie Ray Vaughan Warren's book about
drinking coke for about,
uh,
two years.
You woke up every morning and dissolve cocaine into a glass of Jack Daniels and
drank it like rocky drank Diego
dummies.
When you're done with doing the line,
you always put the number on your tongue or on your,
makes your whole mouth numb.
Said drinking.
It must make your whole body and specially in whiskey.
So it's like,
it's an upper and a downer,
you know?
Wow.
That's basically basically a living hell.
We'll the,
he was just apparently,
I mean Richard,
uh,
our,
Aaron Pryor rather later in his career he had a real problem with trucks and
every problem with cocaine and so it was very likely that he might've had that
problem even while he was like an elite athlete.
And if you gave them just a little bit in the corner like there was no drug,
I'll give you another fight as a,
as a boxing fan.
I ran Barkley and Duran.
Fuck yeah.
Holy Shit.
Roberto Duran showed that even though he was like,
he was in his thirties at the time I ran a bar who's bigger?
Stronger.
I ran back to the,
knocked out.
Tommy Hearns did knock out turns before that or after that.
Uh,
before,
before I ran bark.
It was terrifying.
And Roberta around boxes face off the same way.
Did a Davey Moore,
I just,
exactly.
I just wish you would've done it to Leonard.
I just,
I guess maybe he couldn't find them,
whatever.
Go grab them and just beat him up.
Who knows what happened.
Man,
that second fight,
Frank Sinatra got paid.
That's what happened.
It could it be that a lot of people thought that he was paid to take a dive.
The DRN took a dive.
A lot of people thought that they didn't train and just partied like a fucking
wild animal.
Actually beat Leonard the first time.
He was one of those guys are one,
$4 million in a fight and then two months later after a bunch of booze and
cocaine,
a new shoes,
he needs to fight again.
He gets like these big white gold shoes and he gets heavy and then it needs to
box again.
He's a classic story man.
He's a classic style over Berto around.
Oh,
he's one of my all time favorites.
Joey Dee has gotten his book many,
many years ago because we would always sit around and talk about Roberto Duran.
Right?
She always a huge Roberto Duran fan,
so it gave me his book.
It's amazing.
Guy had an incredible life.
I'm sure he did a lot of boxes.
If you think about it,
probably have,
you know,
because they're brought up knots.
I think,
yeah,
it's hard to be at the highest level without being a little nuts.
You got to nurture the physicality and then the anger and then before you know
you've got a pit bull at attack your neighbor.
That's what you want.
I was watching a video of Mike Tyson from 87 training with Kevin Rooney and they
were hitting mitts and you see young Mike Tyson who was like,
no,
I don't think he was like 20 or something at the time.
I don't know how old he was,
but he was just fucking these myths up.
Just just move so fast for heavyweight and all that Bob and weave and shit that
he used to do,
like he bumped and weaved after every combination,
every combination she would throw in the past and going down.
It was short and he would,
yeah,
they'd mentioned him.
Yeah,
dude,
but even in the pants,
like that's how he did it when he was working in the past.
He's just,
well,
it's constantly in motion.
Something else.
Again,
I met a mental,
a mental thing that happened.
That's what I think emotionally,
you got to stay tough a long time,
man.
We,
even Ali,
he went,
but he lasted long enough.
But Tyson,
you know,
a couple of years and then he went crazy.
And I don't blame him for,
I'm not saying I don't blame a guy for going crazy.
Yeah.
I mean,
look at the,
look at the men who live in that car dash in house.
They all eventually go nudge that.
That's atmosphere.
Like Lamar Odom starts smoking crack.
And of course we're a,
Bruce Jenner has a pushy,
you know,
he's getting one.
Yeah.
And it's really difficult to believe,
well to be at the level that a Mike Tyson was at his point in life at a really
young age,
20 year old champion of the world.
You know,
he's,
he's out there doing whatever he wants to do.
Basically buying Bentleys crashed them,
giving them the cops.
I mean,
he was just off the chain,
crazy owned the lion.
I mean,
he was just crazy.
You can't get any crazier and you can't keep that up.
It's like this and that's not a sustainable life.
And now I listen.
I don't live a sustainable life so much less that I,
uh,
I have decided that something's got to change.
I mean,
I'm pushing 50.
What's got to change career?
Certainly not the careers.
Y'All gonna make me money.
I'd love to shoot pool with sweat.
I'm not that good.
It's making it happen.
Just train.
We get,
that's the show.
That's the reality show.
[inaudible] joins the pro tour.
Joe,
we've known each other a long time.
I gotta I gotta I gotta stop.
I gotta have that.
I'll have a party or something.
You're going to have a party and stop.
What working.
Just done.
I'm just going to,
I'm going to buy a huge chair and eat myself until I fit it.
Then
I dunno.
I,
I uh,
I got road coming up.
You like doing the road.
So I liked doing the road because I go with my friends or brain comics.
I like to open for me and we have fun.
How many guys you burned?
It depends.
Sometimes two,
sometimes one.
I like,
I like going on the road with a friend.
See,
I've tried that.
I've tried bringing friends of mine to open for me and I still miserable.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Mostly because I don't let them in my room.
Oh yeah.
I like a lot of them,
but I,
it doesn't get me over the,
the lady,
the multiple shows him one night where you got to reboot and then get the
multiple shows.
A tricky if you a free ball,
your material a lot because he gets to that second show you like,
I'm not exactly sure if I did this.
This show are less shy and I'm just going to tape it.
Yeah.
Oh No.
That's happened a bunch of times.
Why repeat a joke.
Holy Shit.
I was drunk once in Pittsburgh.
Okay.
It's like midnight.
There's a 400 pound guy sitting in the corner and I start to tell the same joke
I told him about 20 minutes before the forger.
Palak guys got like khaki shorts on.
He's got his hands close like this.
And as I started to joke,
he just goes,
he just did it with a real,
real mad look on his face and stop me.
And I said,
thank you.
I appreciate you coming to rehearsal.
They get hostile goes all right man.
I'm gonna try to fuck well yeah,
I made a mistake.
Some people just demand perfection.
Yeah.
Well this guy didn't look like one of them.
We get very angry if there's any mistakes going on.
Live performance by an intoxicated man who you love.
Well you know,
guy comes all the way to see ya.
He's got a fucking treat you like that.
How dare he,
he lived across the street.
He looked like David Beckham.
It was a beautiful,
do you think is gay that I feel Chad Ochocinco is David Beckham dipped and
fudge?
Um,
first of all,
I think it's a huge insult.
The Chat Osho Sinco cause he's far more beautiful.
You like him while he's just looks wise.
I mean his,
if you looked at both of them naked,
you would definitely be able to tell if it was in black and white.
Who's who?
They're both the same color shadow just and goes a different kind of athlete I
guess.
So that guy's a fucking freak athlete,
but he's fucking up.
He's not around.
He's not throwing her son.
It's hard to keep that going.
Like we talked about earlier,
we were talking about him so we know who he is,
we know who he has.
A lot of people know who he is,
which means he probably,
at least for a short period of time,
he got fucked a lot of money and before that probably didn't have any money.
She,
I think I,
I don't think you're giving,
you know,
his problems and merit.
I mean,
I agree with everything,
but the man did change his name to Otros Cinco it's 85 in Spanish.
If you're normal,
you don't do that.
But we are talking about them.
Yes,
sure.
I mean we can talk about Hitler to what,
what,
what is it,
what's the criteria?
What do you want to talk about?
I think for,
no,
but I think for those guys is what I'm saying to those guys.
Like it's important to get your movies,
stars,
whatever,
you know.
I think that's a good move to call yourself.
Otros Sinco we're,
I mean otherwise,
I don't know.
I don't follow sports so we really wouldn't know.
Well,
I don't have a Jersey number,
so I'm like,
you don't,
I'm going to change my last,
my last name to my cholesterol level in Spanish,
which is of course rd clock,
trow,
Dojo crow.
That's going to get any,
a lot of pushing.
That's hilarious.
What else are you been up to?
You just do this on the road basically in the UFC.
A dude's,
it's still the VFC scheduled.
You're like so busy.
I'm pretty busy,
but it's all stuff I like doing so it doesn't bother me this weekend.
It's at the staple center and every,
every man.
No,
I don't do everyone.
There's a lot that I don't do.
There's a lot that are,
uh,
like the Fox sports night ones.
Most of those I don't do,
some of them I do do,
but uh,
what we do,
what we do in recently is we have a bunch of guys in here and we watched the
fights and do a podcast podcast while we're watching the fights.
That's really fun.
Yeah.
I did that with the super bowl because I have a $30,000 bet on it and it was
kind of weird to see what happened.
I won five grand.
Jesus Christ son,
I want to fly,
washed on the fucking coin,
toss to a grand.
Did you really immediately,
you know,
pissed off a few thousand dollar coin toss.
I was down two grand before the game started.
Terrible.
But I ended up up five g's.
I had to patch and had the patriots in the over.
Did you like gambling?
That's one thing I could tell.
As soon as we moved to gambling tonight,
Brian Regan wanted to hustle us.
We had to play a $20 game at nine bucks.
I ended up walking away with a double Savak.
Yeah,
he won't.
Fives and mine and he got out like four or five balls in a row,
like not,
not an easy out.
You got out.
Oh,
I appreciate your one game and already cleaned it up and know you won the first
day.
You're in bed on the first til you one,
but we're just playing and then Reagan wanted to hustle us.
I thought he was going to pull out the real game.
Yeah.
Ree and lipstick.
Maybe he grew up in my list,
you know Irish name,
but you want a pint night pool game.
All of a sudden he's a fucking pirate.
That's hilarious.
I was trying to do Charles Dickens.
Oh,
I got confused.
I never know what that guy sounded like.
Me Too.
That was a fun time.
Are you enjoying doing podcasting now?
No.
Why didn't you like it?
It wasn't an I,
I'm not,
I'm not an ambitious guy.
My point is like,
you know the rob Lowe,
like the audio line.
I'm more like the Stop Caring Rob Lowe.
You know,
I'm that guy like in the contract.
Oh,
right.
That commercial with the caveman level.
Oh,
I'm,
I'm the other guy.
So,
uh,
you know the podcast,
I mean,
I do it in my kitchen.
I've been late eight times.
Well,
what don't you like about it?
You were so good on the radio.
What would you like on the radio?
I like,
I like to,
I like talking like this and saying stuff on the radio.
You don't like organizing it.
And doing anything.
I just let everybody else do it,
but then eventually I need something done properly and it's a mess.
Man.
That just seems like a logistics thing that seems like that could be handled,
but you're a really fucking funny guy and you did not have a podcast and be
ridiculous.
You know,
you've been a couple,
there's a couple problems that you've had over the last few months about tweets
and shit.
Like we read those tweets off.
We were fucking howling.
Oh,
I think there was anything wrong with it.
I get on Twitter,
I said,
look,
this is hilarious.
Like you think.
Do you think he really means what he's saying?
Of course.
That's what you're so stupid.
So stupid.
He took Joe not,
you know,
it really is a,
it really is growth in either one of those things you said was mean spirited.
It was funny shit.
No,
it's funny.
Self deprecating and in the one where I'm Thomas Jefferson and the black guys
all carry champions of Shah,
the slave where Carrie champion is my slave and I'm,
I'm her master.
I point out that I,
I do not a Jack Hewlett until she escaped.
You're saying that you would have her beat you and you'd come all of these and
I'll just say,
I'll go one further.
I'm saying when I be seeing,
when I see an African American woman get her freedom and break free from the
chains,
I just blow a load over the Blair.
Oh,
so you have to see the freedom happen in order for you to come.
You're a freedom of justice warrior led Jizzum ring.
How dare you see,
I don't think there's anything wrong with you being incredibly excited and
sexually aroused at a woman achieving freedom.
I think that we should all be another owner.
Can you think,
do you think you are capable of coming equally from a man achieving freedom or
maybe a game and though
you got to come across the board and everybody will be happy.
Oh,
I'll come when people get free.
Don't think I could come for a man.
I really don't.
I don't think it's possible and that then I'm going against the man getting
free.
Oh a man getting through,
man.
Getting free,
like the same way for of us slave mail.
I'd be more happy about it,
but I just moved clapping.
But it's just your outlook.
Yeah,
as a controversial of course.
That's what comedy is about.
You know,
and I look,
I know you're trying to be funny.
It's funny.
It's what it is.
It's not like you're some fucking politician.
It says some nutty shit that nobody expected out of nowhere off camera.
And you catch them like this is his real beliefs,
but whoa,
we just found out that already loves slaves.
Like no,
you're a fucking comic.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like I'd really hire,
they get a slave in my house.
It made me angry and I made me angry.
Very angry.
It was terrible.
It's just so silly and it cost me something.
Of course we an appearance on a talk show was trying to care about,
but still they,
they took something from me and that's when her happy we got in front of me,
boom.
Now go fuck off.
We win.
But they don't,
they don't see what happened.
Got a lot of people on your side with that.
You've got a lot of people who enjoy that kind of comedy.
I always talk about Brian Holtzman like hell he has,
he says ridiculous,
cruel shit,
but I think it's hilarious cause I know him.
He's a sweetheart of a guy.
He used to do this joke about Susan Smith or the chicken drowned her kids.
He goes,
sure.
I heard those kids were bad.
I sat back,
close it,
put away their blocks.
Those tests will not be missed.
You got to see him doing it to understand that you can't take it out of context.
You got to see his whole act.
It's ridiculous.
He says
a bunch of really and then he laughs at himself.
He's being funny and it's,
it's an art form.
Just like a violent movies and art forum.
You don't really killing people.
Whoa mate.
When,
uh,
just to prove your point where I went to match.com after I broke up and they
give you a form thing you have to fill out and have to be honest in the
questions is I could,
I could never be honest in those questions.
I've got a girl who looks like she's an isis.
So I did that.
So I,
I uh,
I got to the part where it said what's the worst thing we've ever done?
And I put,
I actually put that down to see what kind of reaction I get.
And uh,
the worst I,
one time I had sex with a retarded girl and to get rid of her,
I put her on a bus.
How did that work?
Well,
I don't know.
I haven't seen her since,
but do you know what I mean?
It's for mass.com.
Did you put that on?
I didn't get the date.
So you know,
I,
I'm not even gonna get into that either.
That's shocking.
I bet.
Just people didn't think it was really you.
I bet they didn't want to get catfished.
Who would these take it is someone pretended to be you writing retarded shit.
They probably didn't think it was here.
That's the only reason why it didn't work.
Now that people know to check that page later,
I,
you know,
yeah,
I don't have,
I don't have time.
So you like doing this,
you just don't like the hassle that comes with like organizing it.
Yeah.
I'm not an organizer.
I'm not a prepare or not prepare,
but so you just want to show up and be already weighing.
Yeah.
Now they're letting me do that pretty much.
But you know who cares about that or I,
it's got people got to start listening and otherwise you're just do something
else.
I thank God I got my stand up and you know,
well you don't think people listen to your podcasts?
Like what do you mean?
Well,
I mean there's not a ton of people listening to it.
No.
Well you're doing this subscription based thing,
right?
Yeah.
But I can't get sponsors.
I called people.
What do you mean you can't get sponsors?
Because I said a couple of things.
Listen,
just say,
sorry.
Say you're sorry uncle already I refuse Jesus.
I think you can get sponsors.
I don't think there's a fucking question in the world that you,
you,
you could get sponsors.
They only offer I had was sphincter during the Ashman.
It's an [inaudible] and he put it in your ass.
If it's a fleet,
everything up before someone eats it out.
Yeah.
That might kill people.
You be careful about that.
That stuff that's like give you toxic shock of the asshole July them.
Uh,
I dunno.
Job Ellis.
I appreciate it buddy.
You're a good man.
I think you're a good friend.
I,
I've just given up.
Don't give up.
I don't care.
Look at me.
This is what I looked like.
I don't care.
Yeah,
but you do care enough.
You care enough to be funny.
You care enough to make those funny tweets.
My,
and I keep making you son of a bitch.
Oh,
I gotta make money from my mother.
Does that what you're doing?
Yeah.
My mother is,
she's only way she'll be on welfare if it wasn't for me.
It was I,
this is crazy.
I got to get out of this.
Wow.
Not this.
I'll stay here as being comedy,
doing comedy or podcasting.
I could do black hair thing,
you know?
I don't know.
You could do,
I don't
do it.
But You keep going.
Yeah.
If someone like sets it up for you.
It makes it nice.
I haven't shut up,
but it's not a studio.
I think the were a lot of people were doing wrong is they're trying to get paid
from podcasts right off the bat.
And I think it's,
it's,
it's kind of hard to do that.
I know Anthony has been pretty successful.
Anthony Kumiai,
you know,
he's got a very,
very devoted following already on his,
like he had that video podcast set up right before we ever did it.
That's one of the reasons why I wanted to do this.
Anthony has a fucking full studio in his base with a green screen.
Wow.
He's had that since like 2006 or something fucking crazy like that.
He's always experimented online and he's just kind of a tech genius.
Right,
right,
right.
So he built up this following and then he started hiring,
you know,
having people do subscriptions when he left Opie and Anthony.
But I think that if you start off,
look,
I've listened to some of your podcasts.
They're hilarious.
You're funny fucking dude man.
Always thank your.
Always funny.
I enjoyed you on that,
nick.
Depaulo shall,
we couldn't swear.
That was fun.
It was fun.
We're with nick.
A little suit.
What happened?
I'm tired.
You know what I mean?
Like I went through a lot of shit.
We need to pump you up.
We need to get you interested in my friends.
Orange juice.
Fresh squeezed.
We're going to gallery Kale.
Are you ticklish?
I tried a new trouble and I put a lot of Kale and onion rings every time I took
a dump and sound like James Caan getting shot.
My God.
Yeah.
Yeah,
the chicken.
The end.
Oh,
I'll figure it out,
man.
I'll let you know.
Well,
what do you want to go?
Bike riding the mark.
You don't have to do that.
You don't have to go bike riding.
And what do you want to go?
Let's just,
you need to,
you a slide like talking to and hanging.
But I want to do like an elliptical machine went.
Yeah,
well,
you know what you need to do.
You just need to get motivated.
We need.
Uh,
are you,
uh,
if you're not in a relationship,
that's what you need is a super hot personal trainer.
Motivate you.
You got some of those numbers.
We know they're all over Los Angeles.
Couple,
I don't know for you.
One line,
we'll find some.
We're going to use the power of the Internet to find Artie Lange,
a beautiful fitness trainer who's going to motivate him to get in shape.
He's just going to see her just glistening in the sun telling you,
come on already up the hill.
Can I pick what color?
Well,
yeah,
you want a black shirt or white checker for Chinese?
I'd like a nice Taiwan.
I like a nice Mocha,
Mulatto type.
Ooh.
I don't think you're allowed to say Mulatto anymore.
I think they took that from,
well,
I'm going to win the Mulatto.
Oh,
describe why you should do a podcast.
How could you not do it?
Now you know what I,
you know what?
I'm going to get your number.
I'm going to text you about this.
I need some advice.
I need,
I use it and a couple of minutes of your time.
I need some advice.
I think we could,
we could get you a 10 times increase in how many people are listening to it.
Right?
It's not about my health at all.
All your health to you and I.
There are a lot of people listen to that.
I got,
I need more,
but my health is what I'm talking about.
Well,
it's,
it's you.
It's real simple.
I mean,
it's not,
it's not simple psychologically and it's not simple emotionally.
That's the hard part,
but it's real simple.
Eat really healthy foods.
Your body will get leaner,
you'll lose weight.
It's really that simple.
You just got it.
That should be all.
How the fuck am I going to hard to do?
It's hard to do.
It's hard to avoid.
I mean,
he came in with a cheeseburger.
I do know.
Did I?
Yeah,
he came in with a cheeseburger.
You were joking about it being gluten free.
Can I really?
Yeah.
I was very with that.
I eat them all the time,
man.
I eat cheeseburgers all the time.
I eat two of them.
The other day I was at a fucking food truck in Portland.
It was so good.
I had a tie.
Bacon cheeseburger.
God Damn,
it was good.
That sounds unbelievable.
It was insane.
He'd had grilled Jalapenos in it and that peanut Thai sauce,
like saute sauce or whatever it is.
Fuck.
Holy Shit.
It was so good.
I had to go back and have another one.
It's a,
it's a place called the brunch box and Portland was a little food.
Trucks get it and they give it to us for free.
They wouldn't even talk about money,
so it gives them good for you.
Good street food,
cod,
Tam.
It was good.
There's nothing wrong with a little bit of that every now and then,
but what you need to do is just figure out a way to discipline yourself,
but I don't see that happening unless you're like a long shot,
but I'd like your support.
It's a long arch,
a long shot,
and I would just accept you just putting one down like,
yeah,
I think are just going to do it.
You could definitely do it well before you were being sarcastic.
No,
you could do it,
but you keep saying like,
ah,
what am I going to do?
How's that going to happen?
Like you gotta like the side that you're going to make some sort of a gigantic
change,
but it's fucking very difficult to do.
You know they won't take,
they say one day at a time.
That's really bullshit cause it's every 10 seconds at a time.
You're right.
The timing 12 I have had the stop in the last six months.
It's literally,
it's not a short list.
It's like a,
it's booze,
it's heroin,
it's coke,
it's pills,
it's sugar itch,
gluten.
It shakes.
Don't have a cherry.
If you have an orange,
peel it this way and if you drink water,
only drink it cold.
All right.
What does,
how the fuck am I going to live to you?
Everything I know I can't do anymore.
How much of the life pleasure that you get out of life revolves around food?
It's just below the heroin pleasure.
Not Food is a sensuous thing,
man.
Come on.
It just central which thing it is and it's very difficult,
very difficult to you're off especially really good food.
Yeah.
I love,
I love a nice male,
Oh,
who doesn't?
Who doesn't?
But what you can do if you really want to like restructure the way the whole
thing works,
but he's just earned those meals and it means even more when he got it.
I do.
I go to work,
I make money and I pay for is he do,
but I mean earned.
I'm like psychologically by trying to take care of your body.
Those other meals reward my shelf.
Like give yourself like five,
six days of eating good.
One day you're allowed to go off like a rocket one day where it's just fucking
linguine with sauce and fucking Lasagna and steaks and milkshakes and whatever
the fuck you want one day.
But all the other days really healthy.
Really.
Lyrics like real foods,
vegetables,
not six days.
One healthy one night.
If you just did that,
you'd have a radical change and cut out soda.
If you're going to have to drink soda,
if you really have to.
It sounds gross because Diet soda has aspartame,
which probably gets brain cancer,
but it will definitely be better.
Story gets better and better.
It'll definitely be bad,
allegedly gives you as,
I appreciate that.
I'm gonna try.
Believe me.
Yeah.
You think I'm bullshitting?
I'm going to try to live like that.
I have though.
Otherwise I'm not gonna be around.
Yeah,
listen,
you too talented till it slip away.
W we needed just someone to come along,
some professional to come along and deal with that aspect of your life.
Deal with you.
You know who did it?
Kevin James.
I know you're having,
James hired a professional chef and some sort of a whole foods like um,
this woman,
like she specialized in like green vegetable shakes and she had this crazy diet.
I forget what the Diet was,
but she was like,
Kevin hired her and this woman would cook for him every day.
She would cook all these like really lean vegetable based diets.
This fucking dude lost 70 pounds.
He would.
He's where I got the Kale shakes idea from all now from when he hired her,
he was what?
Your six of kings queens.
I think he had retired,
I think two campaigns in loaning me.
There's money for the higher the the queen of vegetable and he's just rolling in
cash.
Like this year.
He's just got his arms open and just rolls around in his bed,
right?
Yeah.
He has like a shoot pulls on the top of his bed and money comes out of the
ceiling.
How many bays in it?
Like that scene in decent proposal with Demi Moore and the cash in the bank.
I had to me my friend chef at least lane and from kill Tony,
I,
Russell Peters just hired her because he gained a bunch of weight and all she
does is like cooker,
cook him a healthy meals.
So he has it in his house.
So when he gets hungry he's like,
I'm going to go to Mcdonald's.
He goes,
oh wait,
here's,
you know,
a healthy meal that's already made.
Wow.
Yeah.
If you could get someone to do that in Hoboken,
I bet.
If you got,
I bet you would be able to get someone to do that just based on your podcast and
based on the results that they think they can get you,
how much good that would do them in advertising.
I mean,
could you imagine?
But we can't just wait for the food and you know,
their services,
like they donate their services so that you can promote them.
Well Ho boogers closed this year cause Sinatra's hundredth birthday.
You can't do anything in town.
Really?
Yeah.
So I got to go somewhere else.
Wow.
The hall for place closed down.
They just play Sinatra songs really,
uh,
up until December,
2015.
So the whole year they play Sinatra Song pretty much every other night.
But then the week he dies it's going to be insane.
Oh my God.
[inaudible] is,
April is a,
you know,
a Pepperoni scone,
chill,
Super Pershad,
Gaba gold freshman wizard dot weapon,
which dials roasted pepper,
fuck the thing.
And you go right into the food bucket shake.
So
I'll go to the gym first.
I love Frank Sinatra.
I had a dog named Frank Sinatra.
Did you really?
Yeah,
I uh,
you gotta like the Francis,
you gotta like the Chairman of the board.
Yeah,
I'd love to songs,
especially when I was younger,
but I didn't know that they had that much of a following for him.
You didn't know,
you didn't know Sinatra had a following you?
No,
no,
no.
I mean like where they would have like a whole year of nothing for knowledge.
It's actually at hall Bulger,
man,
that's some rays.
It's amazing.
I mean it made sense.
It's where it came from.
You know,
you'll appreciate this Joe.
I said somebody had 60 minutes or some of the talk show was talking to him in
the mid seventies and the,
the interviewers said the Sinatra Frank.
How do you feel when you hear that the criminals,
like Charles Manson say if they ever break out of prison,
they're going to kill people like you Shirley Maclaine,
Dean Martin,
what do you say to that?
And without missing a beat and actual look to the,
what did the guy and said let him out.
He just said let them out into nothing.
And then the guy got scared when?
I don't know,
basically let them out.
I'll kill.
Wow.
He wasn't bullshitting either.
I don't think so.
I mean I,
if I would find that out,
you know how many people's in Nacho must've known.
I mean he was the god of the Italian world.
I live around a block from where I grew up.
Really?
It's nuts.
Who's got his house?
Who owns?
Well,
it's an empty lot.
Of course out of respect.
It's a social club right next to it that they play a poker at.
Why I was $38,000 or one night,
you know,
allowed to talk about this on the air.
Like where are they play as years ago.
Oh,
they're not there anymore,
man.
Ben Doesn't,
no cop is going to tell him to stop.
That's just that spot and that spot.
Yeah.
Wow.
You like Hoboken.
Love it.
You got a beautiful view,
right view.
I look at the whole city and the view of the city from outside the city is
actually better than the view inside.
I agree.
It's good to look at the city but not be in it.
I have a friend who lives in Brooklyn and he,
he's got a um,
a high floor,
like he's a like on the 10th or 11th floor and it's above the river.
Like just looking out across and you see the bridge to the right.
It looks like framed.
It doesn't even look real really.
You look out his window,
you're like dude your view isn't even real.
That's the kind of view I have.
I got lucky.
I have these single best view of Manhattan from the Hudson River side.
It's like a painting to me there's like three great views in the world.
It was a lot but there's three,
three of like three archetypes.
One of them is the nature of you like mountains to me a number one with that
like mountains in a lake cause he,
those two of them together.
That to me is like the most spectacular thing to look at.
But the other two are two different types of city views.
There's The New York one from across the river.
We had it and you realize like,
wow,
this is an amazing place.
Like we've got the size of this,
this hub of life and humanity.
But with the weirdest one is above doe.
Heeney a lot of people don't even know about this one.
You go into Hollywood,
you go into the hills above doe Heaney and you're looking down over the city and
when you're looking down over the city it looks like blade.
I know what you're talking about it,
it doesn't look real.
I do those though.
He anyone.
Yeah,
it's,
it's not my friend Larry used to have a house up there and it didn't look real.
Like you would look out as Yardi go Pauler you're such a ball.
Yeah and it's scary.
Oh my God,
it's scary.
Alien like you're looking down at a space ship.
Like it doesn't look like any other view I've ever seen.
I've taken photos of it.
When you're flying in you kind of sort of get it,
but you don't get it.
Like you get it when you're looking at someone's back porch.
Cause he had like one of those infinity pools and like you would sit by the pool
and you'd look out off the balcony like,
oh my God,
look at this fucking view.
This is insane.
He's like living in a science fiction movie,
but that helps you get up in the morning.
It was like,
wow,
there's going to nature.
You can't be in a bad mood.
Yeah.
It's like art,
right?
You're like,
it's like you're looking at natural art.
That's how I was like me.
I look at Shawn,
I have route three and she cook.
It switches.
There's usually no trouble.
No trouble.
You look at the atmosphere,
forget it.
You can't be in a bad mood.
Yeah,
well you can,
but you're silly.
Yeah.
I avoid it and that's saying a lot.
You avoid nature.
No bad mood.
Oh,
do you see yourself becoming a man of the woods someday?
No.
Packing up.
I would just lay down just like that.
I would lay down,
I would go,
listen,
I'm just going to wait to a road.
I see a theme here.
There's nothing I offer.
You need to be motivated because you're obviously very,
very funny.
You get somebody to come along a little comedy.
I drive like get up.
I got a check.
I come back.
I mean what the fuck?
I'm not,
I'm not a bump on a log here.
No,
you're,
you're in.
You're in action,
but you look like you're maybe not enjoying some of the action but you shit.
Mitch called withdrawals is maybe a little,
how long does that last for?
22 days.
Now when you go to a doctor and you get like your blood work done,
they check out all your vitamin levels are the worst stuff.
Sure,
sure.
Everything.
Diabetes.
I'm diabetic too.
So what do you have to do for that?
You got to take a pen.
Boom right there.
How often he takes two seconds.
Once a day.
Is that a recent thing and 25 units?
Two years.
Last two years.
Last two years I've had to take the insulin.
Before that I just had to take the pills.
And is that related to like diet?
Is there a way to turn it on my show?
It's very much related.
It's much almost a hereditary and diet are the two things,
you know.
Damn Dude.
Um,
well I could see how that would weigh you down.
I can see where that would weigh down.
That would fuck with you and make you feel like,
you know,
the pen thing isn't bad.
But I mean,
just the fact that you've got diabetes.
I mean,
that's a mind fuck.
I had finished,
I'd forgotten about it for a couple of days,
but yeah,
you're right.
I'll be all right man.
I hope you'll be all right.
I'll be good.
I'm not going.
No,
I don't want to.
I know.
You know,
I want you to like podcasts.
He too,
because I got excited when you were doing it.
I,
there's like a sky.
I like it a lot.
I got about as much or like anything else.
So everything's kind of,
Eh,
well where's that coming from?
I didn't say that.
I like it as much as get anything else because things like,
hey,
just too good at it,
man.
You're too funny.
Yeah.
Do you think it's like a defense mechanism?
I don't know.
Problem.
I'm pretty good at that.
I'm pretty good at spotting sparknotes.
Listen,
if,
if I've noticed nothing else in life.
It's that.
Yeah,
that Joe Rogan is very perceptive when it comes to
getting a laser and getting right to the heart of a comedian
and getting to your ability to play pool.
As soon as you start stroking the,
as I look at this motherfucker,
you would,
you're,
you're a great shooter too,
but I have a table here.
I have,
you know,
I'll tell you one thing that is a little impression of about that.
I have not shot pool and eight months easy.
I haven't picked up stick.
Well it makes sense because like it took you a couple shots to get loose.
Well here comes in,
there comes a negative.
A negative at all.
Well you said it was great shooting.
Listen,
I suck at first too.
When Regan and I first day.
No,
you're,
you just kept playing.
You walked in after I'd already wow.
Okay.
Well that's nice.
You did a minute.
No,
no.
I was knocking bald in the rail.
I'm sure online it takes a while to loosen the arm up,
you know,
I'm sure,
especially if you have a play date months,
I haven't played in two days.
So there you go.
In one week I won 22 g's hustling line ball.
Jesus.
Best Week of my life has a as a place,
a place,
but I was 19.
Oh,
I got me and my mouth.
Maybe my buddy makes up this other kid up.
Beat him every time.
Oh,
so you got a mark.
Here's what,
what happened.
Uh,
me and Deidre pretend we didn't know each other.
We get getting a game with a third guy.
Okay.
We don't know each other.
We're not friends.
Let's play three way,
whatever.
It's like a movie.
20 bucks on a five $50 on a nine.
Okay.
I made sure I went before deach.
Uh,
no [inaudible] made sure he went before me.
So every time deeds would go,
he'd miss on purpose,
but set me up for a perfect shot first on the five,
then on the ninth,
that's a little area.
So you guys just kept robbing this one dude?
Yeah,
we want,
we want about 11 games in a row.
Wow.
Poor bastard.
I proud of it.
Now the guy seemed like a bit of an Asshole,
but we've,
we thought,
my God,
we got the greatest fucking system of all time.
And then there's a couple of times he would set me up,
but I'd miss,
and he'd look at me like,
what the fucking door.
And then one guy,
Tommy,
I'll never forget this.
We call them red hair,
Tommy,
because he had red hair and a,
and he had like a big,
big curly red hair and red hair.
Tom.
We found that what we were doing,
he just wants to make it like,
I like,
you know,
you mother fuckers know each other.
You've got his brother who's brother came back with a snowblower.
He tried to run us over fucking snowblower and,
and pool cues.
He threw me over the table.
Uh,
my one buddy,
his friend was,
was a cop and he just flipped.
He flashed the guy's base.
That guy got the really scared and those days were fun.
When I first started making money,
I got a development deal with Disney and a part of the money I use to back my
friend Johnny B.
My friend Johnny B was like a professional level pool player.
A hair off with a pro speed.
No kidding.
Yeah.
But he could,
he could win tournaments.
It would win turn.
He could beat a lot of guys like to write the average person.
They would play him.
He'd beat the average,
who couldn't be like,
it's very rare that ever beat like,
like a real top pro.
But he beat some like lower level pros.
He was a really good pool player,
but he was a slick motherfucker.
Right.
And I would take them on the road.
We would,
we would go all around,
like we'd go to jersey,
we'd go to western billiards,
we're talking about the APP.
I put him in the tournament,
we'd see if we could get a game.
And then we play at executive leaders in Chelsea,
Chelsea,
which was downtown,
which is to know exactly where you're talking about,
you know,
Chelsea billiards.
Yeah,
true.
I know.
Yeah.
So that was my addiction phase.
Like I was badly,
badly addicted as eight hours a day for like a bunch.
I went through uh,
a good long phase of pools who absolutely so fun.
So fun.
It's a blast.
It's a real short of hand eye coordination get slow.
Like the best thing about the hustlers,
they can play for 18 hours in and misses a shot and he just looks over at the
shade and said,
well you cut out that white.
It's Kinda depressing,
but you're like a dark,
easy Pang and then you leave,
you know?
Yeah.
They're guys who do play those kind of long,
24 and 38 hour gambling session.
[inaudible] has happened.
I know that.
I have that in me.
Nope.
I like a few hours to pool.
Those are brutal.
That's a young man's game and it's fucking super healthy.
Like to stay up that late trying to concentrate and drink coffee at the pen,
which see the great thing about the hustler is the whole premise was Gleason
could shoot,
no matter how much booze you had,
he handled his booze.
That was a skill.
Whereas Paul Newman,
that's George Scott to handle his booze.
Picture those three guys in a movie.
How could that be bad?
That'd be bad.
And Piper Laurie too.
Yeah,
she just cute bag.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a great fucking movie.
Those,
those places just was so interesting.
That was what I got addicted to.
It's where all the people that didn't follow the rules went well.
That was aims billiard,
you know that that was a legendary place on 14th street that shot a closed in
the mid seventies.
But aims was where,
you know,
name is played there.
People had Gleason.
I love to have seen that if it's stuck around,
but they uh,
but they knocked it down,
but aims was where they shot it and he dealt with the turn of the century in the
19 hundreds there was something like a thousand pool halls in New York City.
Wow.
That was a thing to do,
man.
Before video and all the shit you shot a in the pool.
That's what they do.
I mean,
people,
it's lost favor.
People don't understand what video games came along and other Games of leisure.
And not the same thing because it's,
it's,
it's really not on a lot of levels.
Human contact.
It's not even indirectly.
At least pool is indirectly.
It's,
it's not even close to human contact.
As a matter of fact,
it's light years away from it.
You know what the pool players blame it on a lot.
They blame it on casinos,
like card casinos opening up.
Right.
You're right.
Because then people who were,
who loved to gamble on things,
they didn't have to execute.
They're like,
if you're playing cards,
you have to pick the right cards.
You have to make the right choices,
but you don't have to physically execute like stroking the ball and missing a
shot.
All that pressure on nerves fucks with some people.
So I like it and they're like,
that's what killed the pool game or the pressure on nerves,
pressure and nerves and it's a lot of face up to,
there are a lot of them on.
There are a lot of them.
Yeah.
So like attendance and pool halls dropped down and attendance and his card
places.
These guys that didn't,
they didn't have to gamble on pool anymore.
Now they go play legal cards.
I,
and then of course that cuts into a pool,
but yeah,
yeah.
Some of that.
Watching a guy shoot a game of pool,
like just dancing around a table,
keeping the stick on there,
looking around,
looking at the angle,
Bam,
Bam.
You know,
one of my good friends is this guy,
Max Eberly Max several.
He's like one of the best players in the world and I,
I played with him all the time.
It's always frustrating,
but just watching them,
I could just pick up like little slight things that he does.
Just watching them move.
Like he always hits the ball the right speed.
It's always always dead on the next ball at the perfect angle.
It's like it's artwork and what English you put on.
Yeah,
it's an artwork.
You watch a guy who's just so good at that game,
then you appreciate it.
But I think it's one of those art forms.
It's only appreciated by people practice it,
but well,
it's like rap.
I didn't think rap music was a talent until I heard someone who couldn't rap.
I said,
okay man,
that's new.
It must be good,
but it's not on the level of pool.
I mean pool is a true sort of,
you know,
a less sophisticated version of chess.
You know,
it's,
it's a,
it's American Jess and a lot of ways and it's perfect for a barge burglary.
Young guys that get together and bond on it's,
yeah,
a setup perfectly game.
And you get to use your hand eye coordination.
It's my favorite in the world.
I love it.
I love it too.
I wish it would.
Uh,
we need to make it,
make it come back already and come back as shoes.
And the next time I was shooting pool on TV or something,
I'm saying we need them.
Yeah,
we need to make it.
And you'd have a comeback.
Why don't we have a tournament?
Let's do it.
Joe.
Get in.
Don't even fuck with me.
I will do.
I know.
You will love it and be fine with two I'm talking to.
Yeah.
All right,
well I'm in you.
You absolutely let me know when I would play in to pull.
Joe wrote,
you want to call it Rogan's?
No,
let's come home talking about how to do it,
how to do it and we can get some other comics.
A polite Fitzsimmons plays down.
My Rep,
I know the pilot.
The pilot's was a pretty good game of pool.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
He didn't know.
He didn't tell me he held the acquity he was here.
He didn't talk Janeane Garofalo was great.
I heard but I heard she is a true,
how she gets rid of the ball.
She shoots it like one of those tie ladies.
Those things that tug Stan Ho talks about
match.
If that was the handicap,
you know people are always making crazy bets.
Like you know you have to shoot every shot with the plastic bridge would.
If it was like you can,
you can play but you have to shoot with your poster stuffed up all over.
That's called America.
There's a woman out there somewhere in the world that can knock,
pull balls in where her pussy for sure.
Alright.
Yeah.
Her name was Mrs. Lang.
I'd like that.
It must be right.
Don't you think?
I mean someone's figured that out.
Some of this has to be a genre of porn thousand videos dedicated to like
billiards coming to the girl's vagina so we can only help that happen.
But by the time you think of something like that,
for sure that's already been done.
I mean they've think of them own the most deprived shit in porn these days.
I would imagine there'll be playing pool with pool balls coming out of growth.
That's kind of rough.
Maybe the smaller balls like maybe snuck her sneaker as my English friends would
say.
That's an interesting article that might not be of the dungeon.
Yeah.
Have you ever watched a game of sneaker?
Do you know drive in him?
He played snare.
Yeah.
No note how I'm saying it correctly.
She knew very difficult.
Very difficult.
Well,
those guys become a pool players and they always do really well and almost right
away,
but no pool players go over to snooker and start winning big time tournaments.
They've had some sneaker players from Europe come over and clean up.
We had the world 10 ball championships Guy Tony Draco.
Yeah.
Killer snooker player.
I'd like to watch a whole game,
but he gets a little boring without the,
without the pockets.
I really am excited about a Pacquiao.
Mayweather though.
That's the first big boxing match.
I just like boxing so much.
It's a fascinating fight.
Yeah.
I can't wait.
I would,
I would wonder,
you know,
it's,
it's really interesting to see what strategy pack our employees like whether it
just goes at may weather the way it goes that everybody else just fast.
A lot of movement and a lot of rapid combinations.
A lot of angles.
You know,
him and Freddie Roach been preparing for this guy forever.
They're both going to be prepared.
I like Mayweather.
There's a little bigger and I think he watched it more than I think it's
quicker.
I didn't,
may words are quicker than back.
Yeah.
Well he's a very clever,
very,
very hard to the play head games,
especially in this country.
What are you showing me?
This woman shoots a pool ball out of her vagina and hits him eight ball into the
corner pocket so we can't show her movie play.
It's real quick.
Real quick.
You and we'll get upset at us.
I knew it was going to happen.
Here we go and it's coming.
Good Lord.
Yeah.
See,
there you go.
That's the pitching pitching machine from my movie.
I love the fact that that's real.
You know we were right.
Easy to figure out.
You're right.
I'm stretching,
stretching.
By the way,
this church is way more comfortable.
Don't like that chair.
Is that what it is?
I'm just ergonomics stretching.
Oh,
it feels good.
How do people sign up for your buck?
I'm like,
good.
You already quit or.com one word.
A quitter.
And how many times this is you guys right here?
How many times do you guys do it?
A week before.
Oh really?
Monday through Thursday.
Yeah.
And there's a special code.
If you punch in the code,
you get a month of the podcast for free.
Unless of course,
you know an eight year old who would get on youtube and you can get it for
nothing all the time.
Nothing.
All the time.
Was it.
Here's the code to get the free month.
It's a
limit.
14 is that it?
Atlantic 14 Atlantic 14 okay.
For a free month,
a free month of a Ardys podcasts go to Atlantic 14 and how much does it cross a
monk?
699 six 95 well,
I guarantee you're going to get people to subscribe,
but I guarantee you would also get a shit load of people to listen to you online
if just if it was free and then you just get ad for it.
It's just needs.
Just need to be connected with the right people.
All right.
Why six 95 and seven why not?
It sounds better like movies.
I didn't come up with any of shift.
I know that is a weird thing.
These uneven numbers for trickery to make you sound like 70 to fool people are,
oh well it's not seven crazy.
Who is in charge of picking your number?
Who picked that?
Nah,
I don't know.
Some guy,
I hired a couple of guys and he's like,
I'm going to fool them all already.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's fine.
Whatever.
Oh,
it's one of those situations I'm looking to see some test studies where they
actually got like 200 people and say,
hey,
it's either $7 or 695 and see how many people actually that was like the
deciding factor.
Like you know what that sounds do I hit his show right?
I'm telling you.
People have said that.
Yeah,
I'm sure like psychological.
Yeah.
I mean it's not a coincidence that they do it all the time.
We can get a feed her hamster sign up for me.
Well,
a lot of being broke,
especially when you're worried about how much this cost or that cost and like
really money,
your pennies.
A lot of it is psychological.
You're like,
man,
I want to get that fucking thing but shit,
can I afford it?
Fuck it.
I'm just going to go for it.
It's only six 95 you know?
That's why you should just do like four 95 plus two maybe because at first you'd
be like,
for that sounds way better shoes.
Cute.
Confused the fuck out of that to small numbers equal the same number.
Four 95 plus $2 only.
Get already laying.com.
Trying to find,
what are you looking for?
Oh,
do you get unplugged east?
Getting crazy here ladies and gentlemen already laying.
It's just moving about like a wild man knocking cords out.
Think about going on the road with his nine ball game.
There we go.
Beautiful.
We got it.
We're back.
Alright,
we're back.
Yeah,
I'm thinking you me Fitzsimmons and Dom Irrera we'll do a God damn pool
tournament.
We'd do it live on the Internet.
We'll get a sponsor.
We have some fun.
We talk some shit.
It's safe to say I would without question.
Say Yes to that.
There's,
that would be a lot of fun.
There's no doubt about it.
That's totally a good thing to do.
Now that I know you play really good and I had them for our,
like I said,
he plays really good to Fitz.
Simmons plays really good and dom can play
on.
I'm ready.
All right,
we're going to do that.
We'll do a comedy slash,
uh,
you know,
pool podcasts with not many of us.
We do it right out here.
You could even do shows at pool halls,
like I've been to pool halls.
Were there stages too loud?
What do you mean?
Like how many shows do a comedy show and then play pool?
No,
because then you're doing a comedy show to a pool hall.
Like don't you want to do a comedy show at a comedy club?
Like that's where you want to do comedy.
You don't want to do comedy at a pool hall with a bunch of people watching
various games at the bar and talking shit mad that they missed the eight.
Like,
oh,
fucking cunt,
middle of your set and then have to deal with that.
I like that.
Yeah.
I think like this place,
like where it's nice and quiet private,
that's where you want to do it.
Don't want to do without a pool.
I'm in.
You let me know.
Rd Langley's Jen can play better than you're saying.
So he played good.
I could tell.
I mean Ping Pong.
Ping Pong.
Yeah.
I Dunno how to play that.
It looks the same thing as pulls his hand eye coordination before,
but you have to practice it.
Oh,
you'll be fine.
I see what you practice here.
But I could see how much you love gambling.
When we started playing for money,
I can tell the little fire and that's when I bring it on.
Yeah,
I though life since an excitement.
But the double your net worth on a Virginia Tech game on a Tuesday and you watch
the fireworks fly.
Have you done that?
Yeah.
And what's the biggest bet you've placed?
I,
one time I went $140,000 on the super bowl.
but after everything will hooker,
the commission,
the Yam and I got back on the plane.
I did the math,
I was down five grand
fucker.
Was that
Larry?
This mother Fucker,
you pop it out again.
That must've been one fucking w.
How many days did that take?
Three.
Jesus Christ.
So you were,
you were burned through going nuts.
Forget it.
Just whatever,
just burning through whatever bed is came about.
Wow.
I love the,
you should write a book about just that weekend.
I wrote two of them.
They're both best sellers.
That one particular weekend.
Oh,
that'll go.
Yeah,
that's actually a whole book.
The third one,
that's hilarious.
That is fucking hilarious.
Like God damn dude.
So that's the most you've ever won in some most or ever lost.
That's the most you've ever lost to same around the same area.
Yeah.
Right.
Exactly.
Cause the night I ended up down,
well if you're betting that Haim and if you go bad,
if you have a weird week shifting your real ugly.
Yeah.
Is the worst part is the window a couple of times man it looks you get fired up
again,
it hooks you and then boom before you know it,
what is it?
It's just that is just playing that chemical brush game of like knowing you
could lose a hundred grand and not question the physical rush without question
is so does it get,
does it like pull you,
do you like you feel like if you haven't bet in a while and you feel like you
need to place a bet,
is it like to start and know enough from me?
I'm not like that.
But when I go somewhere and something reminds me of it,
I can put one down and then that could start like a binge going.
I never sit at home craving.
I got a better sampling.
So let's say she's aligned in the paper and I think saying to me what I'm
getting out of Artie Lange cause cause I love you.
You say you're a talented guy that loves pleasure,
pleasure.
I like something.
I feeling something.
Yeah.
And this,
it doesn't have to be pleasure and his gambling thing,
you got to,
that's like cotton deco deep down to the nerves,
first
thing in the world.
It's just like me and him,
me and uh,
me and Norm Mcdonald,
he's do this thing called lightening bet,
which is literally heroin for gamblers.
Uh,
you know the under over is no,
you ever hear that?
What is like,
yeah,
I know what the,
anybody here know what the under overs.
Like I say a,
you've been a basketball game and the under over for the basketball game as 180
points,
which that means is the total amount of points that each team scores has to come
out a total over 180 then you win.
If the total number that they score is below one 80 you lose hence over under,
so a lightening bet is you assign a number,
an amount of money to each point that the bet goes over or under.
Which means if you lightening bet $1,000 on an over at one 80 once you hit the
over,
I get the chills saying,
once you hit the over every single basket that gets hit in the game,
you win $1,000 every from both teams,
both teams.
A basket from the field is to grant a 3.3 grams every single bed housing.
So like the shakes you start to get while you're watching her literally like
they're,
they're visible.
It's almost like you know,
you're having a connection,
have drinks.
Maybe coax calm down and every time a shot goes up it's like Eh.
And to me it's the purest form of degenerate gambling I've ever seen,
I've ever seen.
I wasn't even aware that existed.
Norman,
I was on the road once was six months I was opening for him.
We was the one of the basketball players.
We had a bout 40 g's on every game.
What's it gonna hot,
what's it normally when we just talked about the head,
that famous story where he threw the money in the ocean cause he knew he was
going to lose.
It was that norm either side of the throw it out because she thought it would
just make them lose more but might have very well been urban legend oil.
You're a lot of this could be urban legend or no,
no,
not from you.
I'm saying from,
I didn't hear it from norm.
I agree that that could be a no and I agree that could be urban legend.
Absolutely.
Well everyone knows he's just a wild maniac.
He's the one of the funniest,
smartest human beings I've ever met.
But he's got a true edge.
And a true danger.
And that's what happens.
I love him.
He's a rock star man.
He's a bad motherfucker.
The Rock Star.
He's hilarious.
And he's also like,
that's really him.
It's not putting on an act.
You know when,
uh,
he hosted the espys in 2001,
Oj Simpson was just forced to give his Heisman trophy back to Fred Goldman
because Oj lost the civil suit.
So he had to give money reparations back to Fred Goldman and Nicole.
So he didn't have any money,
so he should take my Heisman trophy for whatever that's worth.
So Fred Golbin takes it and now he owns it.
So the next week or the SBS inform a host,
the Assamese Charles Woodson,
the guy who won the Heisman trophy,
the first offensive guy ever sitting in the front row.
First joke,
norm tells,
he looks in the front row and he says,
Hey,
Charles Woodson,
the man you won the Heisman trophy.
No one can ever take that away from you.
First Defensive Guy to win the Heisman trophy.
No one can ever take that away from it.
And everybody applause.
It's like a real nice thing and it settles down on the normal clothes.
No one can ever take that Heisman trophy away and then he pauses and said,
unless of course you kill your wife in a waiter.
As I go or,
and Bob did it really well.
It was uh,
yeah,
it was at radio city.
Oh,
it was a Ken Griffey.
Jr was like,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
What did they expect?
It's norm fucking Mcdonald.
Maybe not that.
It makes me love him even more.
Norm and I talked,
we sat next to each other randomly on an airplane,
talked the whole way back,
just shot the shit,
talk about all kinds of stuff.
I was like,
yeah,
I quit smoking while ago.
Just done with it and for whatever reason the plane lands and he goes,
man,
I just want a cigarette.
He just walks in this day that he hadn't smoked in like x amount of months,
but just decided to talking about it on the airplane,
how he quit smoking,
that he just wanted another cigarette,
grabbed it,
went outside and he's just smoking it.
I go,
what happened?
I thought you quit smoking.
He goes,
I did.
I did until just now.
I just,
I just wanted a cigarette.
The movie,
me and him die.
I did a buddy comedy with him and it got bad reviews.
So the reviewer of my hometown paper said,
Artie Lange has all the charm of a date,
rapists,
true line.
So norm looks at it and he calls me up and he goes,
hey man,
that's fucking great.
A date rape is tasked to have way more charm than a regular rapist.
Oh,
oh
God bless.
That made me feel better.
Norm is the coolest motherfucker on the planet.
I love him and he's funny and I hope you know he doesn't die broke.
No,
he's,
he's just a real special dude and he's a very unusual guy.
I got to get them on this podcast.
I just never seen him.
You'd have a blessed,
of course,
when I was on a plane with him,
he didn't even have cell phone back then.
I got an answering machine.
They can give me there,
you know,
call him back when I want to.
Man,
that's how it should be.
Anyway.
Who Care?
They can call you back if they want.
Yeah.
I mean it is how it should be,
I guess.
Unless someone needs to get ahold of you right now and then,
well for doctors,
lawyers,
kids,
I guess it's good.
Everything else.
Who Cares?
Gambling Naughty little line is I and I.
I'd rather not know for a while.
You had genuine disdain for me in your eyes when I told you that I didn't watch
sports.
I really saw it in your eyes.
Well,
no,
cause I thought you did what?
You were disappointed when you play sports.
I don't,
I just martial arts.
Okay.
Actual Sport,
right?
Yeah,
I guess so.
I mean to use the I played sport.
Yeah.
When me and you first met at mad TV a long time ago,
I thought you told me that he played second base or you play baseball?
I did before I started martial arts,
but that was one.
I was like 15 I have to stay and I'm like,
all right,
what do you want to put on when you and I had a conversation about boxing
because you played my boxing manager.
I imagine is actually a very good sketch.
It's shot in black and white,
but we um,
and we worked a lot of boxing.
Yeah,
I know we're,
we,
cause we bonded on a chair.
I love bugs and that was,
I enjoyed,
I became friends with you and Cowan from that show accounts.
One of my best friends is Brian's a good man,
but he's a great guy and he loves you too.
You don't always say Brian and Brian and I have a very special friendship.
I love that motherfucker.
He's a good guy and I hope he's doing well.
Tell him I said hello.
You know,
I will for sure.
But it was one of those things.
It was like you two guys were like,
you were like,
when I got on that shows like I saw a lot of competition and a lot of like
competitive angst.
But there was youtube guys,
they were like regular guys to work with.
Cool to hang with and it was like real normal,
uncomfortable,
no Hollywood bullshit.
Well it's a fun place to work and it was good to have somebody like you.
Come on,
we'll get just really fuck around.
Uh,
but that show lasted 14 years.
Complicit.
That's amazing.
I still get checks.
Well,
you know that mad magazine,
I mean that's,
it's about is the a or now on the drug or not?
Absolutely.
But that shit was around in like the sixties or seventies or something.
Fifties.
Yeah.
I think it was Billy Corbin was saying that he used to have all the mad
magazines.
You went away to college.
His mom threw him out and he had like every episode I'm cleaning all the clutter
tossed out.
That's fucking icons of American history.
I'm mad magazines.
Like I used to read that shit.
My parents used to buy that when I was a little kid that's been around forever.
And I was big with puns.
You know,
we'd always have to pitch puns and I would pitch them as a,
as a joke,
not thinking they never do it.
And sometimes they would do it.
And I'm like,
Oh man,
I wish I was kidding.
Like I would pitch stuff like,
uh,
Andre Dawson's creek.
Uh,
he was a baseball player.
rush Limbaugh sings rush songs,
they wouldn't do that.
That's hilarious.
Um,
uh,
Tory Amish and Amie,
they do that.
I mean,
just make it easier.
Did you ever see yourself doing a sketch show again or was it just too much?
Carl Young Man's game.
It is.
I look back at those sketches are merit to be and I'm like,
oh my God,
how did I do that?
Did you like doing that sports show?
It's like this show with you and nick was mostly sports comedy as well.
Nick and I had a lot of fun.
We got to talking about sports be funny and everything and of course the
corporate people tried to make it something it wasn't,
they wanted to a more conservative show and I can't blame him,
but you know that you don't hire me to do sports center.
Did you,
why did they hire you to do a conservative show?
That's probably one of the long line of bad business decisions that they've guys
weren't that outrageous.
It wasn't so off the charts,
we weren't,
I think they just,
the certain little things we said,
you know,
they might not be considered proper English.
They got mad.
Really.
That's the beauty.
That's where the beauty of podcasting comes in.
Like you said,
we sat down just fantastic and I love it.
Look,
everybody who signed up are familiar already is God bless you.
I appreciate it.
Hope people will more about the,
this is the first time I am uncensored,
completely and utter nonsense and I got nobody telling me what to do.
Nobody.
So it'll be fun.
100%.
And you like look because of your tweets,
you know,
cause of the funny shit that you've been saying.
Like you're,
you're in a good place comedically.
Right now you're hitting notes.
I just did a special,
I did.
Uh,
yeah,
everything I've done in the last year I liked.
So yeah.
So is that what's like bringing you the most joy like at this stage?
Like the stand up I guess.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it seems like it's like the most pure,
right?
You get that burst of one hour,
you know,
you'd get it out like stand up man.
It's just like grabbing a mic and change something and it might get,
you get the immediate reaction.
You get a check and you get the hell out of there.
Everything else takes forever.
Have you ever thought about doing like a Vegas residency?
Uh,
not for a long time.
No.
I've been there for two weeks.
Not longer than two weeks.
You wouldn't do it.
It's better than a cash man.
That's how I'm seeing you and Jay gambling in Vegas and someone putting you up
in a casino.
Dude,
I'm telling you that.
Give me a price.
Wild fucking ride.
Any price period.
If you really want to call out like one of those July,
those fireworks shows at Disney and July when they really go off right around
the fourth.
Just,
just,
just give me a number.
Brian Regan,
who was in here earlier,
he lives in Vegas,
but he doesn't work at Vegas.
He works on the road.
Oh yeah.
He uh,
lives but does technically live in Vegas.
He lives like just outside of Vegas,
you know.
And one of those suburban towns.
Right.
But he doesn't perform in Vegas at all.
Wow.
Wait,
what?
Really?
What?
That's not what kids live there,
so he doesn't want to perform near where his kids live at.
Brian Reagan,
one of the best comedians ever was just in there.
It was a pleasure to meet you,
Brian.
I can't believe you'd never met him before.
That's never met Brian.
He is one of my absolute fucking heroes.
Yeah.
He's a great guy.
A real clean and good and original.
Unreal.
Yeah.
He reminds me,
Gaffigan in that sense where they're completely squeaky clean,
but undeniably two of the best comics in the world.
Like it,
Gaffigan doesn't lose anything for being squeaky clean.
His comedy is just,
it just,
he just smashes it every time.
Like it doesn't have to be dirty.
Yeah.
They're the same types of guys.
There's,
that's what they do.
You know?
That's why the beauty of comedy and with a lot of these guys,
it's like,
it just like,
you have to find out who the fuck they are and what,
what did Mitch Hedberg perfect example that guy like that.
That's not like a model.
You can't like say like,
oh a Hedberg type before he existed,
you couldn't like nail that down.
The closest you would get like maybe Steven Wright kind of,
but not really.
My Bergh had his own thing.
I know.
I didn't watch to look around,
see what happened,
you know,
I,
I don't think he was uh,
it was that much of an accident with him,
unfortunately.
No,
Well after he,
you know,
he'd had one health scare from,
uh,
from the heroin and then wipe proves couldn't gang green or something crazy from
shooting at the Samsung.
What happens?
You could smell it to get on a plane.
Yeah,
but what's it smell like?
Oh,
I'm not sure.
I've never smelled it.
I would imagine not good.
Like any sort of,
well,
you're dealing with rotting tissue.
It gotta be like a dead mouse under the couch or something like that.
I'm probably along those lines.
Dead Tissue.
Yeah.
Too Bad man.
What a funny fucking guy.
He was.
Jesus Christ.
Uniquely funny.
A lot of funny people.
Gum.
Yeah.
That one.
That guy that just a over d dos last week.
I didn't know that kid.
Did you know that kid?
No,
I never met him.
I met him through a Taylor vixen back in the day.
Yeah.
And uh,
he followed me.
I followed him type thing to talk to a few times and then I saw him at the clubs
a few times.
Then I use a little,
uh,
what was that?
Uh,
yes.
Widows,
Harris Widows,
Harris Wheels,
poor bastard.
He was a nice guy.
He said,
I mean it seemed like a really nice guy.
I was actually going to have him on a podcast,
but then he like became like a executive producer of that parks and rec show and
I was like,
oh,
this guy has never heard.
It was a really good comic too.
That's where I heard it was very funny.
Very funny writer.
I heard that from everybody.
That's fucking those God damn pills,
man.
Is that how it was that was it pills?
Yeah.
How old was he?
I heard,
I heard it was,
it,
was it pills?
Because I was,
I was told that he was into heroin.
Oh,
really?
Same thing.
One leads to the other,
you know what I mean?
You might be right,
but I had heard of,
I heard it was pills,
bolts,
you know,
that's what you're getting when you're,
you're taking opiates,
you're basically getting the same stuff.
I mean,
it's,
it's hillbilly heroin.
That's why they call it that.
The scary part of it is the,
uh,
the ingredient.
They put it in the flux where your liver,
not everything does that.
Tylenol has it.
Percocet has it.
Uh,
but,
uh,
stuff like Xanax and stuff don't have it for some reason.
I have no idea why.
But your liver goes away quicker if you take Percocet or something.
Bell.
When did you have your first experience with opiates?
Uh,
match?
Probably 14.
Whoa.
What was that feeling like?
It's all right.
It felt good.
The threw up a little bit,
you know.
Wow.
And then,
uh,
I was on an ACD.
She concert in 1981 back in black.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I,
I took a little,
and it was great.
Sniff content.
Never felt that good in my life.
Uh,
no sniffing.
I wasn't sniffing anything.
How'd you take it?
I just took it on my tongue.
Really?
That's all you're doing is putting any jobs?
14 wow.
Yeah.
Wow.
Dissolve them.
Was like Whoa.
That's what need my friend Johnny,
he started out with a lot of,
it was upper,
a lot of coke started out with a lot of coke and crack and things along those
lines.
And then somewhere along the line it shifted to heroin.
Well,
I sort of happens is heroin's cheaper?
It's better for your laborer,
the natural thing.
And then Bam,
that fucks your toe and better for your liver then coke.
Yes.
No,
no pills at worth for your liver that any powder patterns and have to go through
your liver
14 man.
That's insane.
When did it become like a regular thing?
Like how old did you become irregular thing?
18 something like that.
That's 17 1717 so you'd have like periods where you stopped and then periods got
back on.
But yeah,
I could never have done in my career what I did early on if I was on no way.
Didn't make sense.
You can't function.
Yeah.
Wow.
So when you see like this,
uh,
this how many people get prescribed it today,
and you know how much of a pullet has on people when you see me now,
they prescribing it to people all the time when people have injuries.
And let me up until the rubber bands on the injury,
if you really broke your back,
you know,
and your loved ones there yet,
they don't want you to sit in there with a broken back if they really need it,
they really need it.
The problem is you got to go to a great doctor who knows how to Wean you off it,
right?
Because if they don't do it,
you'll be in withdrawals when you get out and then you're physically addicted to
it.
That's the problem.
You're physically trolley poverty,
old saxophone.
I said something.
He said,
uh,
they can get it out of your blood,
but they can't get it out of your brain.
You know,
you keep remembering what it felt like.
That's a problem.
My friend Brendan Chavs fights in the UFC and he,
uh,
was on the podcast recently talking about how he got his nose reconstructed,
broke his nose in a fight,
couldn't fight for awhile and got hooked on pain pills.
It's like they prescribed to him.
He started taking them and he's taken before he knew what he was taking six a
day and he's taking them every day and after the reconstruction is done,
he just can't stop taking them.
It was from months.
Yeah.
It's a shame and he's not that he's not that guy and that destroys your liver.
You might as well get a fungo bat and just hit your liver with it and really
that many pills,
Bam,
Bam.
Especially if you have some booze with them.
Fuck it.
Right.
Is that the only way to party though the booze?
You got to mix it with the pills.
Why is that more dangerous?
Wasn't wearing dangerous to mix the combination.
It's like Bam,
Bam.
It's like a one,
two punch.
Like an overdose as a one,
two punch man,
little water,
little wine.
You marinate your liver,
Jesus Christ that have plenty of time.
Did you ever do it and make bets that you forgot about and wake up in the
morning with like a stub in your going?
What the fuck
did I buys?
We'll do that with,
I told their story before.
I should do that with a Monday night football.
I would bet at five o'clock and then I go drinking and I would be drunk and I
would call it a bookie again at seven 30 show drunk and all I would do is bet on
the other.
Oh,
so all I could do is lose the vague,
the tax for a loser.
Shiloh was the big,
the next day I called a Buckeye,
but I go,
dude,
what the fuck did you might lead her to have Ford?
And he actually said this to me.
He said,
you got to learn a life lesson.
Ah,
I did.
Thanks.
Where's their book?
Your bookies giving you life lesson.
The actress say Gambia.
That's hilarious.
That's fucking hilarious.
Unbelievable already lying.
You've had a goddamn colorful life.
Don't make it dude like you.
The easy way.
Easy.
That's why you man,
you know,
that's the beautiful thing about life.
A little bit.
What I was saying earlier about hanging out in pool halls,
like you meet so many crazy interesting character.
Do you know?
And it's fun.
That's why it makes sense that you could play pool.
Well,
I promise you your balance.
Yeah.
And uh,
I could win a lot of money with those other people too.
Well though I'm still ones or bear.
Well that that hustle that you guys have is pretty strong,
but that's it.
That was,
that never failed except the one time I came,
I never feel,
think about it.
Your buddy sets it up.
It's like boom.
Yeah.
He just babbles it just hits the point of the pocket and leaves it there.
He's like Pete Carroll on the fucking seat.
Hello.
Oh Man.
That's hilarious that you were doing that for so long.
How many times do you guys think you played that played,
what did that Hustle
and seven years?
Probably 3000.
Okay.
You're just robbing
people that,
oh,
we're just gambling that if you'd check it,
tricking them.
I use it for the right thing.
It's smart though.
Look,
it's a,
it's a clever move.
It's America.
It is.
It's a free enterprise.
Come on sweetie.
Give me a break.
Have you ever gotten in trouble for gambling and is there a way like the,
they ever tried to get you to tell who your book is?
Your I got arrested for gambling once and my buddy that too and we both kind of
dummied up when they let us go.
You dummied up lean mean you didn't know?
No.
Well I don't know what to say and they have eventually have to let you go.
Monkey and Makino.
How long do they keep you for three hours.
I mean three days.
Three days for gambling.
That's hilarious.
This faction of gambling,
they should have gambling three days in a country like Yakov.
Smirnoff says they want that.
They want to be at somebody's beggar and I,
I just saw Biagio as much more afraid of the other person.
Then the cops,
I just was,
I didn't know.
So I said,
yeah,
they have nothing on me.
The lawyer said they have nothing.
Might get three days just shit here and shut up.
So every time that somebody asked me to go,
uh,
you know what's going on?
Yeah.
You gamble with this guy like Nah.
Gamma howling gale.
I mean big cat.
I don't know.
So how did you get caught?
Like what was the circumstances?
The place got raided.
The pool.
So you guys are playing cards?
No.
Pool Pool.
Gambling Pool.
Shooting Pool.
Wow.
Three days.
The major ring.
This happened in other words,
card tables in the back.
Oh,
okay.
So it was a sweep.
They were trying to get all of the connected folk in the,
in the neighborhood.
You could smoke that if you want.
Let's face it.
Joe's shut up.
You think so?
Someone in inside rash.
So I still don't trust a couple of people who not man.
Tell me more.
Mother fucker.
This mother fucker's judges have a guy who announced all the games on the radio.
His name was Jim Gordon and she would have a bet on the game and if you made
mistake.
Yeah.
If you had a ton of a bet on the game and he was on the radio,
if you've made mistakes,
you didn't know what the fuck was going on and uh,
you know,
it would get,
it would get nerve wracking.
So you know,
you'd have all this money on the game.
And here's what Jim Gordon would shame.
Sims drops back looking for receiver.
He's going way deep,
long,
long way down for beggar,
baby touchdown giants.
We drop it,
get physical pain.
And then he got the mega,
takes the ball in his own 32 he crossed with fields.
45,
40 35 30.
He's go man to beat the kicker.
He's buying the kicker.
Comscore.
No,
he stepped out of the five.
Oh
one time.
One time I had $500 to my name.
I put $1,000 on a giant game.
And here's what this cock sucker shut on the fucking fuck.
Radio
giants have the ball fourth and goal from a one,
two of them alone.
Jetpack handoff to,
okay,
maybe,
Hey,
wait,
no,
I can't see it now.
Work from Toyota.
Oh,
that's what that mother fucker done.
Listening to sports on the radio while you're gambling is God craziest fucking
thing ever.
It's very difficult to do.
Well,
that's how people did it back in the old days.
They had to Joe Frazier fights on the radio Frazier.
When the right hand down goes Frazier.
Yeah.
There on the rainy
Joe Louis and Max Schmeling at the garden and drag.
Exactly.
Yeah.
They used to have those events where people would huddle over the radio and
listened to sporting events.
I used to do that with baseball.
They used to hover over the right field fence with their legs waiting her charge
of field,
but for the last that was made that there their leg was in play.
That's certainly not allowed.
Yeah,
certainly not alone.
My grandfather used to do,
especially games that weren't on television.
He would listen to him on the radio,
sit in front of his fucking couch,
listen to the radio on a Yankee game.
Wow.
Be Very connected to what happened.
They're very excited about it.
Thank you fam.
Yeah.
There was some gambling and my family,
my grandmother was involved in running the numbers and she got arrested and she
wouldn't wrap them out.
So they put her in jail for six months and she was like,
kidding.
Yeah.
She would make sweaters for the guards and Shaman.
That's a woman.
She was fresh off the boat.
You know,
she came here when she was,
God bless young girl.
When you come here,
when you're a young girl and you grow up with that like first generation
immigrant family,
but that's a different kind of animal.
She was the blood sugar.
So you don't wrap people out back then.
You don't,
that's what I'm saying.
I'm not talking to you.
I'm sorry.
I think you have another show that you have to get to.
I don't want you to leave though.
Tell you everything's a big,
a big fucking arrangement.
Is that what it is?
If you've got a bunch of people telling you what to do,
you could smoke that just smokey.
You don't have to stuff it smoking.
I got fucking,
there's a lighter a or a lighter show.
Not now.
Oh,
sorry.
Here's,
here's the,
there's one beside you.
There's a little
more like we have an air cleaner on right now.
Probably is not that good.
I'm going to watch the smoke drift.
Well,
we'll see if it goes towards the gutter cleaner at all towards me.
The fuck you shut the hump.
Sorry.
You Go.
Where are you supposed to go after this and,
well,
this has been something else.
It's been faxed.
You have a dinner with somebody,
especially a specialist.
Let's just say it's a very special,
let's just name that I'm having dinner with someone who is named,
uh,
well his name rhymes with shmedium.
Nishan.
Wow,
that's cool.
I'm playing a vigilante sting at a film.
You,
the mastermind of the organization that leads him to his daughter that's been
kidnapped.
All I play a Cabbie.
He kills him the first three seconds.
You snapchat.
Wow.
He's kicking people's asses at 80 a lot.
I mean,
it's like he's really cashing them each kitchen and all this,
but it wouldn't an unlikely scenario.
The guy becomes an action star deep into his fifties,
I think,
or 60 yeah.
After his wife dies.
Yeah.
How weird.
Every,
all of a sudden he's kicking everybody's ass.
Like all these taken movies.
I have a very special set of skills.
Know where was all that before this,
before he was like,
you know,
a reasonable man in movies.
It took about obnoxious people,
Rob Schneider.
So Rob Schneider was going to do a movie with Steven Seagal.
He told this story on stern and he goes into the sick calls,
a dressing room.
So God comes out of the back and he says to Rob Schneider,
I just read the greatest script ever written and rob some.
And my God,
that's great.
Who wrote it?
And he said,
I did.
You never know who you're gonna run into.
Those guys exist.
Yeah,
they know.
And they exist out here more than anywhere.
More than any guys.
50 of the 50% of this town works.
The other 50% function,
the 50% town that works.
Wives.
Whoa.
Strong words.
Thank you so much.
I think there's definitely a lot of people out here that are like that though.
There's a lot of boards in the world.
They are.
How do you stop that?
How do we prevent that rd.
You try to hang out with the right click of people,
right?
And if someone gives you shit,
you repeat the mantra.
My therapist told me in the late seventies,
which is of course your verbal bullets are nothing against my arm or of shelf
confidence.
Wow.
Strong words.
I remember that one.
That should be like on Instagram.
The time you're feeling down just a member though,
there will be a photo of you.
I predict someone will put up on Instagram with those words and you smile and
holding a cigarette.
I told the,
I told my mother,
uh,
if she ever died,
I'm but three,
three words on her tombstone.
Just said what?
I said bitch could cook.
That's all your name.
Grandma had a photo of her with some of the,
some of the food she cooked for your Super Bowl party.
A big aluminum tray was that if you're ever anywhere near my house,
you have to composure with sausage and peppers,
meatballs with fried green peppers,
gala mod and the Rigatoni would meet.
So let's go a little salad
bread.
A little lot of salon.
I'm getting excited.
I got a quick fucking shoot.
I got you.
I would a lot of things and drink it out.
Come on Henry.
I'm worried about you.
You may fall down the questioning
dude,
I'll fly in for that.
What do you want to lay it away?
I'll tell you what you've planned for that I have laying for the,
uh,
the front of the tournament tournament to deal the pool tournament.
I'm showing you ever no idea.
I know you're in no idea.
I could see him after watching you play today.
You please,
I need you to be and you'll be in a flash.
We'll shoot some pool.
I'll say that the dom and table,
they might fucking,
are they good?
Are they good?
Are you guys back down?
No.
Dom and dom is the dom is good though.
Not these guys.
Dom's good and uh,
Adam Ferrari is pretty good and Greg for Tim is good,
but these guys not so good.
Amen.
But you're the,
you're the like,
you're the front runner.
Ferrara.
He'd get out pretty good too by Craig can get out to Greg.
You can get out all right.
Pocket anymore.
I'm good.
I'm in man.
You're like a world champion,
right?
It's a pocket plumbing.
Ace,
ace in the hole.
Uh,
I in all honesty,
I'm in and please,
I'd love to see it back east.
But,
uh,
Joe Dash for dash support me to man went up.
Bullshit.
I appreciate it man.
You are a real comic and I love you.
I love your personality.
I love,
I love you.
Let it go out.
We go back a long time man,
man.
Sketch at 95,
right?
Yeah,
this is a long time,
but you've always been cool.
I've always enjoyed your company.
Thanks John.
Thanks Mike.
I appreciate it.
Um,
what,
what was already quitter?
What has this,
what does that,
it's just,
I already lying was taken and uh,
I noticed that this poet Charles Bukowski had on his epitaph.
Don't try.
His thing was,
and that's all it said.
It goes to the art of quitting is underrated.
And I said for Pcaob quit something before I die.
So that's what that means.
Beautiful.
Rd.
Quitter,
rd.
Quitter.
Yeah.
Already quoted ladies and gentlemen.
And already a your podcast website.
One more time already quit.
her.com is the same place I already quit her Twitter rd.
Quitter,
all one word.com already laying on such a tax.
Thank you brother.
Crew Tax Joe.
Ah,
no,
it's fine.
Man was
okay.